just explain a little bit about why you
decided to answer that question today
well i came up on the reshuffle in the
shuffle uh so i obviously asked i tried
to get a question every week and it's
actually over a year since i got a place
on the order paper so it seemed to me a
good thing to do ahead of ahead of the
commonwealth government uh heads of
government meeting and for this reason
the government has been very strong
quite rightly on going after the war
criminals who are perpetrating these
atrocities in ukraine but for 16 years
now these fugitives from rwandan justice
who are alleged perpetrators of
hideous war crimes have been living in
plain sight in the uk
16 years neither extradited as the
rwandans wished nor tried under british
laws these are terrible crimes in which
they are accused and of course in africa
many people say well this is because
they're not white europeans the british
judicial system the british don't care
about the fact that these are murdered
black africans they only care about
white europeans that's why they take
such a strong line in ukraine and as a
as a british member of pond i'm very
offended by that but the evidence is
there on the table 16 years they've not
been sent back to rwanda as so many
other countries have done with those who
the rwandan government have sought to
extradite and they're not being tried
under the british system either and the
police say it will take years and years
to address this point and it isn't good
enough and it's very bad for britain's
international reputation and what did
you make of the prime minister's
response to your question
well i mean you know he he he's not
obviously very familiar with this issue
but he promised that he would get
familiar with this issue and that was my
aim and purpose that when he goes down
to rwanda undoubtedly you know the
president of rwanda will say to him
you're very happy to send your asylum
seekers here why aren't you uh either
prosecuting in the uk or sending back to
rwanda these people who are alleged to
have committed the most terrible crimes
against our citizens you mentioned there
the deal uh struck between the uk and
rwanda to send asylum seekers to rwanda
the first plane due to leave next week
but of course it's had this challenge
in the high courts and do you think that
policy needs to be dropped
well i i think that the rawannas have a
very good reputation for helping out
with humanitarian situations they have
taken
desperate people who were caught off the
coast of libya from the struggle there
and give them a new life in rwanda and
the rwandans are trying to be helpful in
a humanitarian way they did the same
thing for the israelis but my issue with
the policy is that i don't think it will
work and it's incredibly expensive for
the british taxpayer i'm not opposed to
britain if someone comes here illegally
seeks asylum is processed in the uk and
is then turned down for asylum if if
then the british wish to deport them to
rwanda and rwanda is willing to take
them i wouldn't i wouldn't be against
that but this is a policy which will be
extremely difficult to implement will be
hideously expensive for taxpayers and i
just don't think it will work that's my
main objection and how popular do you
think these kind of policies are with
the electorate it felt like for years in
a way um being tough on immigration was
being seen as a bit of a badge of honour
something that would always go down well
with with the population uh at large
do you think that's changed well i think
you know i think that this is a
i think this has brought up a lot of
people up short it's just not the sort
of thing we would normally do and and
actually you know there's no alternative
but to do the hard yards of processing
people probably employing more staff to
process them when they get here having a
better relationship with the french i
mean you can't do anything about the
core problem which is people coming
across the channel in a leaky boat
putting themselves into the hands of the
modern day equivalent of the slave
trader you've got you've got that's the
prime problem you've got to have a deal
with the french so so that's the second
thing you need to do and you need to
revise the
1951 geneva convention on refugees
because that was set up before there was
mass travel before there was climate
change driven migration um and and
there's no there's really no alternative
uh but to do those hard difficult things
if you're going to get this problem
under control and say you're going to
ship a few of them off halfway around
the world you know it's it's not very
nice and it's not really the way britain
does these things another uh policy
where you need to do the hard yards is
what's happening northern ireland and
the impact of the northern ireland
protocol uh there and lots of people
extremely concerned about it the whole
administration of course not up and
running until it is sorted now the
government is claiming that it's legal
uh for it to act unilaterally to change
parts of the protocol um do you think in
your view it is well i'm not a lawyer so
i i don't know i would rely on
independent uh
legal advice on that point but
i do think that the european union is
being extremely difficult i think they
need to be much more sympathetic and
understanding about the issue of the
border in northern ireland and the
problem this is creating which which we
do not want to imperil the peace
agreements that have been set in in
northern ireland
and i've been in the house comments long
enough to remember those terrible
statements made after atrocities took
place you know we need to honor the
agreements that have been reached so i
think the eu need to be more sensitive
but equally you know you don't sign a
big international treaty and then a few
months later decide you want to go back
on your word and the last thing britain
needs now when our economy is so
stretched at the moment and there are
these huge difficulties with the cost of
living is to have a trade war with
europe where the americans our closest
ally are on the side of europe so this
is a time now for very cool heads very
good negotiation and a real
understanding by both sides of the
issues here but but i do think the
european union is not being as helpful
or as sensitive to these big
international problems as we have a
right to expect
now of course uh this week i think 41 of
conservative mps voted to say they had
no confidence in boris johnson you were
one of them
what would you like to see from boris
johnson going forward to
get your trust back on him
well i think he needs to
govern in the same way he did when he
was mayor of london he needs to
up his game as prime minister and the
problems he's seeking to address i think
i think there's a whole range of things
he needs to do there's a lack of
coherence and a lot of policy these are
very big issues to do with energy costs
the cost of living inflation growth you
know the critical thing in the british
economy is to increase the level of
growth and we need a laser-like
attention from the prime minister and
you know if 32 colleagues change their
minds he will be out of office but uh we
need to get on with tackling the
problems that my constituents have sent
me to westminster to try and address and
not go on about this day after day do
you think there could be another vote
then you said that it just ticks another
32 to change their minds well there
won't be another vote at the moment for
a year and we've got to respect the
conventions that says things stand but
there's there's a lot of events you know
in politics it's events which come
around the corner and surprise you
and the key thing is he's got to get on
with the job now of delivering the best
possible
answers to these very very serious
problems and this sort of lack of grip
on policy has got to be addressed